we start off in life being very
interested in pleasure and fun in our
earliest years we do little but hunt out
situations that will amuse us pursuing
our hedonistic goals with help of
puddles crayons balls teddy use
computers and bits and pieces we find in
the kitchen drawers as soon as anything
gets frustrating or boring we simply
give up and go in search of new sources
of enjoyment and no one appears to mind
very much then all of a sudden at the
age of five or six we're introduced to a
terrifying new reality to the rule of
duty this states that there are some
things indeed many things that we must
do not because we like or see the point
of them but because other people very
intimidating or authoritative people who
may be almost three times our size
expect us to do them in order so the big
people sternly explain that we'll be
able to earn money buy a house and go on
holiday at thirty years from now it
sounds pretty important sort of even
when we're home from school and start
crying and tell our parents
that we just don't want to do the essay
for tomorrow they may take the side of
duty and speak to us with anger and
impatience beneath which there is simply
a lot of fear about how people who can't
complete a simple homework assignment on
volcanoes and want to build a treehouse
instead will never survive in the adult
world questions of what we actually
enjoy doing what gives us pleasure still
occasionally matter in childhood but
only a bit they become matters
increasingly set aside from the
day-to-day world of study and a reserve
for holidays and weekends a basic
distinction takes hold pleasure is for
hobbies pain is for work it's no wonder
that by the time we finish University
this dichotomy is so entrenched we
usually can't conceive of asking
ourselves to vigorously what we might in
our hearts want to do with our lives
what it might be fun to do with the
years that remain to us it's not the way
we've learned to think the rule of duty
has been the governing ideology for 80%
of our time on earth and it's become our
second nature we're convinced that a
good job is meant to be substantially
dull Aksum and annoying why else would
someone pay us to do it
the dutiful way of thinking has such
high prestige because it sounds like a
road to safety in a competitive and
alarmingly expensive world but the rule
of Duty is actually no quality of true
security once we've finished our
education it in fact emerges as a sheer
liability masquerading as a virtue duty
can grow positively dangerous the
reasons are twofold firstly because
success in the modern economy will
generally only go to those who can bring
extraordinary dedication and imagination
to their labels and this is only
possible when one is to a large extent
having fun only when we are
intrinsically motivated are we capable
of generating the very high levels of
energy and brain power necessary to
stand out from the competition work
that's been produced merely out of duty
will have a limp and lacking next to
that done out of love the other thing
that happens when our work is informed
by our own sense of pleasure is that we
get more insightful about the pleasures
of others that is of the clients and
customers a business relies on we can
best please our audiences when we have
mobilized our own feelings of enjoyment
in other words pleasure isn't the
opposite of work it's actually a key
ingredient of successful work yet we
have to recognize that asking ourselves
what we might really want to do without
any immediate or primary consideration
for money or reputation goes against our
every educationally embedded assumption
about what could possibly keep us safe
and is therefore rather scary it takes
immense insight and maturity to stick
with the truth that we will best serve
others and can make our own greatest
contribution to society when we bring
the most imaginative and most
authentically personal sides of our
nature into our work duty can guarantee
us a basic income but only sincere
pleasure led work can generate sizable
success
when people are suffering under the rule
of duty it can be helpful to take a
morbid turn and ask them to imagine what
they might think of their lives from the
vantage point of their deathbeds the
thought of death may usefully detach us
from prevailing fears about what others
think the prospect of the end reminds us
of an imperative higher still than a
duty to society a duty to ourselves to
our talents to our interests in our
passions the deathbed point of view can
spur us to perceive the hidden
recklessness and danger within the
sensible dutiful path
you